おはようございます。
アイプリニュースのお時間です。
2026年6月9日、最新のアイプリ関連情報をお伝えします。
まずはアニメおねがいアイプリの最新情報から。
6月14日、日曜日の朝9時30分より、第11話いのりのたからものが放送されます。
今回のエピソードも、人気キャラクターのいのりを中心に展開し、ファンの皆さんにとって見逃せない内容となっています。
公式から公開された予告映像も好評で、放送を楽しみにしている声が多く聞かれます。
続いてゲームおねがいアイプリの最新展開です。
6月4日から稼動中のおねがいアイプリ2だんでは、新アイプリキャラクターおりびあが登場しました。
おりびあのバズリウムコーデや、あおいとぐみのデュオコーデにも注目が集まっています。
また、サンリオキャラクターズとのコラボカードも登場し、4種類の新カードとコラボソングなかよしパーティ！
が話題です。
さらに、アイプリバースのプレミアムライブでは、6月10日までバルーンフェスコーデがラインナップされています。
ピンク、ブルー、グリーンの3色のバルーンフェスコーデが登場し、ライブの前後にプレミアムライブのガチャで手に入れることができます。
スタンプを集めるとマイキャラパーツもゲットできるので、ぜひ挑戦してみてください。
プレミアムライブを遊ぶにはおねがい1だん以降で1回遊んだセーブコードが必要です。
グッズ情報もお届けします。
ひみつのアイプリのハピプリバースデー関連グッズが再入荷されました。
書き下ろしイラストやカードイラストのアクリルスタンドが人気で、ちょっと大きめサイズのでかすた！
も新たに入荷しています。
タペストリーはレジで販売中ですので、気になる方はお早めにチェックしてください。
最後に、アイプリ公式からのお知らせです。
2026年夏発売予定のおねがいアイプリ公式ファンブックで、読者モデルとして登場してくれるアイプリを大募集しています。
選ばれたアイプリは誌面でコーデを紹介されるチャンスがあります。
ファンの皆さんの参加をお待ちしています。
今日は大きな新情報は少なめですが、6月14日のアニメ放送やゲームの新キャラクター追加、期間限定のプレミアムライブコーデなど、注目の話題が続いています。
これからもアイプリの最新情報をしっかりお伝えしていきますので、どうぞお楽しみに。
以上、今日のアイプリニュースでした。